Sabrina yeah Brina Sabrina where he's
from virgin where'd you grow I look and
you grab both your parents one pair I
think a common parent oh I grew I was
raised like these two people who call
themselves my parents Amy never did any
parenting actually I guess you could say
they were my employers very young age
they were pimping me out
it's when people call it nowadays um
they started me on like well 5 you know
but I don't five years old the first I
do to just have to sit on these guys so
I have seen all this stuff and and then
later on the subtype just rubs on my
legs and you know I would and find that
job just getting attention you know okay
every kid hungers for attention but um
if I got older you know it went from
just sitting on their laps it's sitting
on other things
um I really uh what would I even you
lost your virginity like maybe like 10
years old
hey yeah about ten I kidded my birthday
was coming up and it was just a guy yeah
my limo mom was a my mom wasn't
processing stuff and um I'm I'm gonna do
very young but I guess I liked it better
that I was even younger my I don't know
and I was like is nothing wrong with
doing anything different
it's not you know it was like the heard
of thing it's aware of so really really
weird people out there but hey I guess
he just didn't ever didn't treat me
badly but they didn't treat me like a
kid either
I had to do some strange [ __ ] I mean
stuff a couple of times I had to do some
things like why should be Seattle II I
never never you know did it but I had to
watch it once more Rose I have to work
her eye dogs doing you know girls doing
with dogs I mean come on parents with a
very like kinky I don't know they were
into drugs you know and they did
anything did any to do for their fix um
my my mom was like she was white but she
was black you know she I don't know she
just she was just weird
she's very very weird I was at home
she'd be blonde woman she's outta she
she to be ghetto you know so I never
really knew who she was I still don't
know she is um yeah exactly when she's
running to her old John's you know she
will hey you remember Sabrina she's just
she's just sit on your lap you know
stuff like that and I'm like looking her
like I think I wanna remember - it in or
do you think he wants to admit that [ __ ]
you know it right now you know they're
all like you're tobert but she still
sees them I guess she was gonna for a
why don't know but um alright it's you
know like right now today they have
their these dungeons out there right
it's like it's an image to think you
know so hey I got the made it's fun
so it's certain extent if you don't know
the safe word yeah style but because
it's really fun you know like when uh
shades of grey came no I was like wow
they're like people like how are you I'm
like you never heard of it
you know it didn't even know that was
just you know ah you can't even now you
know yeah it's the spice yeah that's it
so so you're on the street yes I'm very
much homeless than I am right now I have
a mom
three tenths what not him in Wednesday I
take care of my business a and one I use
for outhouse I was always reaching out
to bring guys home home because you
never know what they might be a sickle
or something like this so I have one I
entertainment couple Bible you know my
company is next door yeah next door you
know he's in fix up like a bordello
it's really nice you know um I I have a
lot of friends you know because I don't
sorry
I don't know and crazy even I am you
know the judge don't make me go way out
I whacked out and stuff you know I can
communicate and you know you know
quote-unquote therefore like there being
a John you know first I don't know Skid
Row is something else is a whole nother
world it's a turn is if you if you can
survive down here you can live any down
where I promise you I mean I keep trying
to pull myself in do away from here I
need somebody like you like sexy weird
well I'm just like why stop coming down
here when I get stories like here I mean
me toss me out
it's gonna burn well you know like um
this is a trip because they do sometimes
you can't do anywhere else
you can't even try doing it anywhere
else if you everywhere else touch your
toes you try anywhere else the great
thing about those skin rollers they feed
you did you feed you they give you
clothes I yeah but you gotta be careful
with the clothes and bear buzzes it was
a mother music there are a mother um
they did documentary and it you know
they did skid row you know you know the
worst thing downtown is the rats and the
crickets
rats figured the new things you call
water bunch of really brunches they're
yeah they're abundant down here but
didn't up site about it is sometimes you
find a family the one who always be
money you know everybody others like all
souls people didn't get us any judge as
a whole life you know but it's hard
being homeless but I wouldn't trade you
for the world I wouldn't trade things I
learned I can't wait to get off these
streets but I wouldn't trade you things
that I've learned I know I'm a survivor
now I know that I could survive anything
yeah my kids don't talk to me but it's
okay yeah family hmm
my daughter's family raised her for a
while we were adopted well my daughter
wouldn't insist and she would never
adoptable cuz she had some intuitions
my son was raised in a system after he
got to a certain age you gotta fight
with his cousin and kind of beat him up
what's a foster care but um I didn't
lose my children to the system my
license to the streets unfortunately I
had many choices for my kids so that um
I could give them a chance and you know
some things I didn't work out right I
didn't abandon my kids I didn't bring
the drugs or my my kids are engineering
that I end up going to jail
from a very long time
or you up work later my first lover
it's a trip because I she was she was
gorgeous but she was evil inside she was
very very I've seen my first lover
because you the first person I ever
loved
she was the first one ever touched me or
fresh and I ever touched but I thought
it up I thought she loved me I know I
loved her but as time went by I start to
hate her
and so to hate her because she was very
cruel to me but she noon I wouldn't I
wouldn't stop see it's the first time I
felt like anybody ever really loved me
so but we got into an argument and one
thing led to another and up I don't know
why I don't know where I got the
strength from but I'll push your ass
down the [ __ ] stairs I was just mad
you know and we were you know tussling
you're not pushed her and she fell down
the stairs who would think that person
but what should happen on TV we were
really happy
did you turn out here to break your neck
what they said you think if we push
somebody in there just run on down here
to get out it didn't happen that way she
died 15
fifteen idea 15 years
that's the only family I knew who was in
jail you know then I got out you know we
get out of prison you go to the
Greyhound when you get here I've been
stuck here ever since
Oh what's your drug to track right you
know what heroin every
hey everybody down here has a vise
rather it's a marijuana prac Carolyn
anything you know has an addiction so
that's what basically everybody down
here has some type of an addiction and
for money to use big guys yeah the
biggest dangers at times right very I
think I was beaten with [ __ ] hammers
choking me out
[ __ ] my action for mistake some kind
of [ __ ] just gonna try to get some money
how much is your cracker he depends like
right now I'm in between doing here.when
you know smoking crack so I don't about
ready to go into a night now and I'm
like wow drugs are so available down
here it's hard to get them till if you
up if you don't want to just more like
you know meaning and you don't
new things that you're not supposed to
go to get the drug and then it's like
also the dirtier you are whoa no more
like a drug out of your home trust you
either die a hero buddy
mm-hmm
that people say that I gave up hope see
everything not the streets well I I know
that I find people who don't
[Music]
I really know what doesn't like a you
know if I was had a opportunity to go
ahead and just say I'm sorry I had an
opportunity to do just lay down go sleep
never wake up but you know I probably
would do it but I'm scared to do it here
to OD doing it because I think I cut
myself I don't know there's I have a
warped way of thinking I don't
necessarily um hang out too much I stay
to myself a whole lot is this the lowest
point of your life or now hold it
49
I've never been this low but hey it's my
choices do you look back at your your
childhood the way your parents raised to
you and
see that that right
have been the cause of a lot of your
your situation today oh I can't read
that my childhood oh my situation so
they could I've had a lot of choices
Eliza I can chosen do different decided
it's comfortable you know do you think
what it is about the spinner other
attracts everyone is that they feel like
this is where they belong that's their
self-worth and so though this is what
fits there yeah anywhere don't feather
flock together that's what I see
everyone seems to be attracted to this
because it fits their clothes obviously
I think it does I think everybody's
diner because there's an anemone you
know you don't have to you can be
anybody when we gather everyone's got a
fake name right
not a 70 right they might have a
gangster name or something like that
no but basically right out here fake
sure you know what you supply it to
anybody
what's the craziest thing you see you
been down here a long time right yeah
variously nicely
craziest thing who seems great oh we see
uh bears thing I've ever seen it out mm
yes
this guy was like used to get high waves
and stuff we we're not finding the girls
behind no he uh he was very well she was
a into it she was screaming and
hollering
she just won her food placemats
and I'm nodding right now so sorry
desert thank you so much for talking to
me Sabrina yeah thank you sorry okay I
by Shannon did a dose before she came
out it's the heroin right yeah I had to
get well you're not the first sorry